Hey I'm Stuart C. Paul and this is a writer's guide to shooting a documentary. This is going to be me taking you through
what I learned while shooting my
own documentary the thing is when you
are making your own movie you do have to
be your own boss and that means you're
the one making decisions you need to
look at yourself not just as an artist
but as a manager of your own time you
have a certain rhythm to your life as a
writer and that's gonna go away it's the
same with a narrative film but
especially if you are a one man or a
one-woman show and you're shooting this
and you're running sound and you're
producing that means that every night
you are charging your batteries you are
offloading footage from your SD card you
are formatting your cards your life will
be thrown into a certain amount of chaos
so the first point I want to make is
that your skills as a writer are your
most valuable asset it's your ability to
observe the world around you
to imagine and the tools you have with
structure your understanding of
character and conflict these are the
things that not only make a good
screenplay
they are also crucial to making a good
documentary I saw the story of project
unfolding in front of my eyes I go to
the yoga studio where one of the
documentary subjects runs her movement
therapy classes and so I saw when there
was a drunk driver that crashed into her
building
I saw them rebuilding and her struggles
trying to put her her world back
together and I was there the morning
that she found this piece of street art
on her building and fell in love with it
and heard as she struggled to get in
touch with the artist and heard the
story when they finally met and
connected and had this amazing creative
collaboration that led to their idea to
make street art together and so that
triggered the writer in me I saw the
scene in front of me you know of this 70
year old woman and this 20 year old
artist going out into the streets of Los
Angeles together and you know that image
that contains the story was what drove
me to say hey I think there's a story
here I think there's a documentary can I
shoot it
they didn't know how they were going to
meld their art forms her movement in
history art to make something new and I
knew that that process was going to be a
large part of the structure and so I
basically after our first meeting went
home and I mapped out the three-act
structure I knew that we would have the
status quo of each of their worlds the
inciting incident the act one of them
coming together and their goal being how
do we combine our art forms to make
street art in addition I knew that ink
SEP was going to be going back to
Vietnam for the first time since he was
10 years old that's something that we
didn't know what was going to happen
there but I expected that whatever it
was would be probably a turning point
for the story so when he went to Vietnam
I had him shoot footage so that whatever
inspired him on that journey could
become part of the documentary when he
came back the end of Act two I always
expect it to be the kind of final night
before they go out into the streets and
the climax of the movie being them
putting up their art for the first time
together and you know seeing this
journey fulfilled it turned out though
that was only the middle of the movie
the story kept going generally speaking
you know for writing a screenplay you
know where it's going to end sometimes
the characters and the story surprises
you but with a documentary you hope that
the documentary then takes on its own
life and the story begins going to new
places and that you are just trying to
catch up when the movie took on a life
of its own
that's when things got interesting Linda
an ink SAP story it began to spread out
from the streets they garnered the
attention of the LA Times there is a big
mural that they are in talks to put up
they've even been accepted to this
exhibition in Budapest accepts parents
were unaware that he was a street artist
and so a lot of what he does in his art
is tell his family's story because they
are refugees from Vietnam and yet he
sort of has this separation from his
culture that he's working through in his
art and him coming out to his family as
his true authentic self
became part of the movie so there are
discoveries that happen along the way
and as it gets bigger you see new
conflicts and again that's where your
writer brain kicks in
when you're writing you always want your
characters to be authentic you don't
want the hand of the writer telling them
what to do you want the truth of their
voices and your actions to just flow
through you and for them to tell you
what happens the same thing happens with
a documentary sometimes you need to
reshoot things or you want things shot a
certain way and that's fine and it's
part of the process but your key should
always be to try and capture something
authentic authenticity is why we watch
documentaries it's what we're looking
for
there's times when it seems like there's
nothing happening and you want to turn
off the camera and sometimes that's fine
if you need to you know save your SD
card if you're saving battery life but a
lot of times the most authentic moments
aren't the ones that you're planning for
or they just happen like when Linda and
ink SEP were driving around looking for
places to put up their street art and
they were driving past the Beverly
Center and Linda looks out the window
and she says there used to be a kitty
park there
you could you could ride ponies there
and that was just to me that was just a
beautiful authentic moment that came
from this woman who has been alive for
so many years who has seen the city
change and is relating that part of her
story to inks app into the audience
one of those crucial parts of directing
a documentary is working with your
documentary subjects communication is
the absolute key as our boundaries you
need to be clear about what those
boundaries are with your subjects what
they're comfortable with what they're
not you may not know it first but you
will find out it's important to know
when to turn off the camera and when to
fight to leave it on sometimes your
documentary subjects will ask you to
turn off the camera and most of the time
that's the right thing to do you should
respect their wishes and do so sometimes
you may want to say are you sure that's
necessary are you okay with me actually
continuing to film this I think it's
important because sometimes their
instinct will be to avoid showing
conflict on film and if it's conflict
that doesn't need to be there for the
movie that isn't important that
shouldn't be filmed and then respect
that but if it is part of the story and
it's part of what is changing in their
world
then you should voice that and let them
know I think this is important I think
it's worth filming
I'm gonna get into a few technical tips
I picked up along the way first off if
you're shooting something you know know
your lenses understand photography I
highly recommend taking photography
class and even if there's something that
doesn't seem like it would be applicable
like outdoor portraits or fashion
lighting you will definitely learn
something that will be useful as long as
you can read your histogram know your
ISO you know know your f-stops how fast
your lens is you'll be in good shape
hold your shot when I went back and
looked at the footage from the first
thing that I shot on the dock I was
astounded at just how often I was just
moving the camera around once you find
your composition stick with it go there
count to 10 in your head and let the
action play another thing to keep in
mind is practicality you want to be able
to keep your rig light and mobile and
have only what you need at the beginning
of the shoot like I was rigged that was
like I had my Shogun recorder I had my
zoom recorder I had my shotgun mic I had
my LED light and I could barely hold
this thing steady it's not going to be
good footage if you're shooting 10-bit
but the footage is shaking all over the
place
strip it down to the bare essentials and
just get what you need I like to run
sound through an XLR adapter on top of
my camera that way I can get sound from
a shotgun mic and a body Michael Ave
that way I have two options for sound
when Linda and Inkscape were out on the
streets I would have them both miked up
and so I would run their labs to a zoom
recorder that I just kept recording at
all times and put in a pouch around my
waist and then I had my camera running
with a boom on top for camera sound and
then you can sync them up later in post
so many cameras today are so powerful
and capable of getting good footage
unless your shoot has a specific need to
upgrade
I would start with the camera that you
have
especially when you know if something is
coming up that is important or that
feels like it's out of your comfort zone
it's important to find someone to help
you and you may have a bigger Network
than you know for instance there were a
number of shoot days where something big
was going down and I knew I needed a
real DP to help me one was the first
time that Linda and ink SAP met to
collaborate on movement and sketching to
figure out the designs for the art I
knew I wanted to shoot it on a gimbal so
that it would be super smooth and sort
of reflect the fluidity of Linda's
movement in her world but I wasn't
comfortable using the gimbal so I called
my friend Pavel who shot The Lord of
Catan my last movie and he shot red
eteri last year he's an amazing
cinematographer and I gave him the
gimbal and knew that in his hands the
thing would sing and all I had to worry
about was following along and try trying
not to get the boom in the shot other
friends also pitched in my friend John
ran b cam for me a number of times and
you may feel weird reaching out to
people your friends and colleagues
asking them to help for little or no
money but if you're passionate about
your project and you can express that
passion to them they will want to help
you
think ten steps ahead to the edit when
you are shooting and you were just
trying to get focus and composition and
good sound but it's important to
remember to get your coverage to get
your wide shots to get your close-ups
and to stay focused on whatever the core
of the scene is in the end you are going
to need all those pieces to make the
final film there were times where I was
shooting except in his studio and I was
focused on his process so a lot of the
shots were just of close-ups and inserts
on the art but during this he was also
talking to me and so it's good that I
got his audio and I could put b-roll
over it but it would have been better if
I spent a little more time on his face
so that I could get that personal
connection to the things he was saying
you are going to be dealing with way
more footage than you have dealt with
before even if you shot a narrative film
and so organizing your footage is super
important
I had a friend run down for me his
procedure and it's works pretty well for
me when you import your footage just go
in and change the file names and rename
them with a prefix like a zero one for
that day's import a zero two for the
next day's import B 0 1 for B cam etc if
you want to get really fancy add in the
date but that will give you unique file
names and will keep things really
organized and you will make your editor
very happy later your editor
aren't you saying oh well I was gonna
edit this myself I thought maybe that's
what I was going to do and then I sat
down and I looked at this 75 hours of
footage I had and I was like no I need
someone who has done this before who has
this kind of brain who has a fresh set
of eyes to help me tackle this
marketing is one of the hardest things
at some point you're going to need to
raise money for us we're running a
Kickstarter and timing is crucially
important your network is important
planning is important communicating with
all the other people on your team who
are going to be helping you spread the
word is big there's social media that
hellscape when we were planning to
launch the Kickstarter I knew that we
were going to have this LA Times article
coming and for me I thought okay we will
launch our Kickstarter at such a time
that the LA Times article drops in the
middle of the campaign and we'll get a
big surge and that's how we're gonna
make our goal and then the LA Times
article dropped earlier than I expected
I had set in my mind this narrative this
sequence of events and then when the LA
Times article dropped early that changed
and my adaptation was okay let's launch
faster let's use that momentum let's
just keep going
essentially it was the same plan whereas
perhaps what I should have done is say
let's step back let's reassess the new
playing field but here I am beating the
drum you know doing everything I can to
get the word out to tell people about
this story and that's why I'm here on
film courage telling you about what I've
learned
probably the biggest advice I have is
just to trust your gut and trust your
instincts the only times that I feel
like I really made a mistake where when
I didn't follow my gut feeling so as
writers we get in our heads we get lost
we overthink things and so if you're
feeling something pay attention to that
because your body is trying to tell you
something and when you're shooting a
documentary it's a more visceral
experience than just sitting and writing
and so you need to be attuned to all of
your senses and your instincts are a
huge part of that
remember to write just a little bit will
go a long way but if that's what you're
best at in the world it'll help you when
you're doing things that you're less
comfortable with and it'll just keep you
grounded other than that I would say
have fun you are making it happen you're
taking a risk you're picking up a camera
you're going out and making a movie you
don't know what's gonna happen you don't
know how it's gonna turn out and it's
exciting so that's something to be proud
of because it takes you know it takes
some cojones to go do that
so enjoy yourself